uh Jamal Bowman from New York who is one
of the most hysterical like really nut
bags I mean the guy's basically
assaulting people every which way he can
and gotten Thomas Massey's face and he's
always yelling at everybody and blah
blah blah uh here listen to his rhetoric
about this thing I'm very frustrated you
know I I called on the president to
invoke the 14th Amendment and mint a
coin and do not negotiate with hostage
takers I mean we don't negotiate with
terrorists globally why are we going to
negotiate with the economic terrorists
here that are the Republican Party
okay first off we do negotiate with
terrorists that's that's number one uh
that's number one number two he wanted
to Mint a trillion dollar coin which I I
I'm pretty sure that was an episode of
The Simpsons which almost everything is
but but that's what they think of
Economics oh we can literally just
create a coin and say it's worth a
trillion dollars and do whatever the
hell we want with everything Kyle I kind
of wish I lived in their world like what
are we all doing wouldn't it be nice and
mad about their conversation they act
like our money is their money that's
that's a that's what they don't seem to
get like their brains their whole way of
looking at at the economy
it's it it's it's all just one shared
pot
so you know who cares if we dilute the
pot a little bit by dumping a trillion
dollar coin into it you know and I it's
just it must be wonderful to be so
childlike and naive and like never have
read uh you know history of banking and
money monetary Theory or anything like
this that says that this scam has
basically been going on since the
beginning of money you know through the
Roman Empire through you know debasing
the currencies it's not a new trick it's
been around for a long time and it
almost always leads to ruin you don't
need to be Adam Smith to figure that out
so uh you know it's just like you know I
listen to these people and I just
you know everything is new to them it's
wondrous it's you know we can experiment
and see see if we get inflation oh yes
we're getting inflation and nobody
should be surprised and nothing happened
like to Libby's Point earlier about you
know we're never gonna not raise the
debt ceiling that is true and we're
never going to not stop debasing our
currency until we have massive demon de
dollarization across the world is if
people just keep dopping dumping the
dollars and uh you know that's gonna
literally I thought of uh negative
things obviously I thought we were the
ones I thought it was those crazy
right-wingers who are always using the
inflammatory language uh he's calling
basically half the country terrorists
yeah they've been doing this for a while
they hate half the country and they're
not afraid to say it and they just
demand that everyone believe that anyone
who opposes Progressive ideology is a
white supremacist even the black people
and Mexicans and from people who oppose
Progressive ideology are racists to
these folks with with an ex I just want
to point that out that was excellent
pronunciation by you foreign